this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
all right so so dante wrote this amazing
text called the comedia this is what i'm
going to be talking about most but he
was as you if you studied dante a little
bit he was part of a brotherhood of
poets uh that were focused on the notion
of love now
love in the comedy can be seen as the
animating force behind everything that
dante talks about and
not only the animating force in the
story but really presented as
something like the animated animating
force of everything that is the manner
in which the world exists
and for us as modern people that is a
very strange thing to think to think
that the world
exists through love let's say but
hopefully by the time i'm done speaking
to you at least understand how we could
think something like that or how it is
that people could could think that way
so
dante has
dante has is this whole massive
experience of going down into hell
encountering all these people that are
suffering
uh for different sins and then
all going up to purgatory encountering
again people that are expiating some of
their sins and then moving up into
heaven where there's this slow ascension
all the way up into god but
when you read the text you realize that
for example the people in hell
they
rush into hell themselves they want to
be there
and there's a sense in which the people
that are at the different levels of
reality that dante encounters they want
to be where they are
and the reason why they want to be where
they are is because of love
that is
it is something like in the lower
spheres let's say in hell and in
purgatory it's something like
ill-directed love
or sometimes lack of love or sometimes
excessive love of things that are good
but that there's too much love
attributed to them
um
so i want to read i'm not going to read
a lot from the actual poem but i want to
read at least a few things from the from
the poem um and so this is taken from
the translation by john chiardi
and uh i'm going to read a little text
from
the
17th 17th canto in the purgatory so if
you want to look it up later you can
look it up
and so in that in that moment in
purgatory there's a little pause and uh
dante's guide virgil uh we'll talk about
why it's virgil a little bit later but
dante's guide virgil gives him a little
speech on love
and he says
neither creator nor his creatures move
as well you know he said but in the
action of animal or mind-directed love
natural love may never fall to error
the other may by striving to bad ends or
by too little or by too much fervor
while it desires the okay so i think
that's that
all right so while it desires the
eternal good and measures its wish for
secondary goods and reason this love
cannot give rise to sinful pleasure but
when it turns to evil or shows more or
less zeal than it ought for what is good
then the creature turns on its creator
thus you may understand that love alone
is the true seed of every merit in you
and all acts for which you must atone
and so love is basically if i'm going to
be simple about it
love is basically that which makes you
move
whatever it is that makes you move in
the world you can understand as love
now
it's strange for us to think that
because we always think about love just
in terms of romanticism or like let's
say the love that we have for children
an easier way to maybe understand it
would be to use a
a word like care for example
or attention
that is
the things we the the reason why we move
in the world is always because of care
now that can mean something like i need
to eat and so i care enough to move to
get something in the fridge
right it it means that i
need like i i care enough about certain
things to get dressed in the morning i
care enough about certain things to walk
out and you know that because you know
that when people become depressed often
it often expresses itself in a lack of
care a lack of love you could say that
is as the love in the person
becomes cold that person becomes unable
to do things and it's not even it's not
like necessarily a physical thing it's
not like they're they're they have an
infirmity in them or that they're
they're weak or that they're physically
incapable of doing things is that
they're incapable of finding motivation
that they're incapable of love or their
love is cold in them so dante a little
bit later in this same in the same
chapter virgil says
all men though in a vague way
apprehend a good their souls may rest in
and desire it each therefore strives to
reach his chosen end
and so everybody in them we have an
intuition of that which is good
and that is what makes us move and we
have a sense that we'll rest in that
good
so this is very simple like it's not a
it does end up in a very kind of deep
theological mystical idea but at the
basis it's this it's the idea that i'm
hungry i eat an apple and i find rest in
that good right i'm tired i go to sleep
i find rest in that good and so
everything that makes us move makes us
move with desire towards something which
we think that will give us a form of
rest from that desire
and so love expresses itself as this
burning you could say in us
that drives us forward towards other
things now this is true of course for
little things but it's definitely very
true about in terms of relationships in
terms of erotic love that is erotic love
has the same structure right we move
into erotic love with the desire to find
rest in that
moment right in that
because a love expresses itself as a
kind of pain right as a kind of
suffering as we long for that the things
that we don't have as we long for our
beloved as we long for that which is
drawing our attention drawing us towards
it right so it's something like
anticipation anticipation is actually a
form of of suffering it's a it's a
strange mix of suffering and pleasure
right it's a it's like this this goal
that appears to you this shining thing
that appears to you in front of you
whether it's like i don't know whether
it's having a good meal in a restaurant
whether it's
going to see
a new play or whether it's seeing your
beloved there's this
this thing that pulls you
and the anticipation is excitement if it
is also a kind of suffering and you you
you move towards
the the possibility of finding rest in
your
in your in the thing that is beloved and
the thing that you are moving towards
now
dante says that
so the idea is that the people that are
everything that is good in you
is
happens through love but everything also
that you need to expiate that does all
the bad stuff in you
is through love as well
and
you can understand that
in terms of a simple way to understand
is like any bad habit that you have
right a bad habit is
is a uh
let's say is sparked by love
and so
let's say with someone who smokes it's
easy to find the very simple bad hat
someone who smokes like someone who
smokes will
have created this pattern of love in
them
which will both
which will make them desire the object
and so if you haven't had a cigarette in
a certain amount of time you're going to
feel that pull and that pull will be
both anticipation and suffering
and then when you take when you get your
hit of nicotine then all of a sudden you
feel that rest
in the thing that you love
and so it's that's true for any
bad habit that you have like whether
it's ocd washing your hands whether it's
like any kind of behavior that drives
you
you'll feel that anticipation that that
suffering and the desire to find
resolution in in in the love
in the in the object of that which is
desired and
so the idea is in dante especially is
that to a certain extent you could
imagine that all things that exist in
the world
are good
they are a good
and that we are meant to move towards
them as we move towards a good at the
level at which they are meant to be
loved so he says
but when it turns to evil the love or
shows more or less zeal than it ought
for what is good then the creature turns
on its creator and so the idea is when
we love something to the level at which
it's supposed to be loved
then it will be normal but if we love
something excessively then it will lead
us into hell
and of course this is something that we
understand like anybody that has been
madly in love with someone can
understand the danger
that
that is there because
it's especially a very strong attraction
if you're very strongly attracted to
someone all of a sudden
the desire to find that resolution
especially if it's unrequited love
especially if the person you desire does
not does not answer your
your desire then then the suffering can
be
huge
and if it's disproportionate
it can lead you into total despair
right and we everybody knows someone to
whom that's happened someone who falls
into despair out of excessive love for
someone but that is of course
something which can happen not only in
terms of
of a lover or in terms of the beloved it
can happen
who's someone who's trying to get who's
applying for a job and that their desire
to apply for that job is so strong it is
pulling them they want it they want it
so bad and then when it is it is
unrequited
then it will lead you into
into suffering
now
it's true that way but it's also true
that if you disproportionately love
something which is not meant to be loved
at the level that you're loving it
then you will have
other problems and so the
alcohol is a great example right you
know you drink with friends you use it
as a social lubricant there's this
there's this there's this capacity to
engage in uh let's say the pleasure that
alcohol can bring you
at a level that is normal that a level
in which it will only act as a
a step into higher loves which is that
you know i like to have a drink with my
friends because it loosens the mood and
then i can really have a great time with
my friends and so now this love for
alcohol which is which is not wrong in
itself is at the right level it's at a
level that leads me up towards a higher
love
but if i become too focused on the lower
love
then it can lead me into despair because
it won't
it's as if i'm trying to make it fill a
hole that is too big for what i'm using
to fill it with
because the the truer love let's say the
love of a person is much higher than
obviously should be much higher than
it's something which will fill us more
than the love for something like alcohol
but if i so if i'm not careful i'm
trying to basically i mean you've heard
you've seen this trope in any kind of
movie right it's like i'm like i'm
feeling something i'm missing in terms
of love in terms of
some desire i have to be loved by my
father whatever like or to love by
someone else and i'm i'm compensating
through something like alcohol um
but this can also be true like i said of
people that is even the love we have of
each other
can become excessive
there's actually a wonderful version of
that in another story which deals with
this kind of voyage into the afterlife
c.s lewis
wrote a book called the great divorce
and in this book he has a similar story
as dante where he he visits the the the
other world
and um
he gets a let he get it's basically
lessons about how we live now it's even
dante's book i'll tell you secret it's
not really about the afterlife it's
really about now it's really about how
we live now the same with with c.s
lewis's great divorce and so in this
book there's a there's a beautiful image
of a woman who arrives in the afterlife
and as soon as she arrives in the
afterlife she asks to see her son who
preceded her in death
and the angel that is there i forget who
the guide is says yes don't yes you will
see your son but before there are a few
things we need to go through before you
see your son and the woman is like no i
want to see my son like i i knew when i
would die that i would see my son so
bring me my son and once again the angel
says no your son is here don't worry
you'll you'll see her son and she starts
to like she starts to get really
animated and she said who is this god
that will separate me from my son like
what kind of god would separate a mother
from
her son and so i want to see my son now
and the answer is no not right now you
can't see your son
and it drives her so mad that she runs
out of paradise into hell
where now she asks she demands that they
bring her son into hell with her so she
can be with him
and it's a very it's a very powerful
vision of even how our human
relationships if the amount of love or
if the manner in which we love those
around us can become uh disordered and
can lead us into
cannot only lead us into a way that
makes us go to hell but really a desire
to bring other people into hell with us
um
this is something which is which is
fascinating something that i've noticed
in terms of bad habits for example you
can see that with uh with people that uh
that take drugs
they have a strange desire to get other
people to do it and it's very
fascinating it's like they actually
invert the relationship where
their love of the drug is so strong
that they they see it as the mediator
towards their relationship towards
others that is they want to pull other
people into their love
almost to justify their love or almost
to to to help them feel that this love
is appropriate and so they'll they'll
actually want to pull
people into their web into their bad
habit with them in order to to kind of
justify their love and so people pulling
others into hell with them is something
that happens quite a bit as well and i'm
sure many people have had an experience
uh experience like that
um
all right i want to read you another
nice little passage from dante
so what dante does is
he basically in his
way of describing the world
he describes what you could call
something like appropriate love or the
manner in which loves
can scale up
can scale into each other how the loves
can build on each other in order to lead
us towards more
let's say to higher more lofty loves and
not get trapped in these lower loves
that we that we all have but that can
become dangerous if we don't if we try
to fill our existential hole with them
you could say um
the way that the whole story is set up
right is that at different levels of
reality you have different people so in
dante's poem there are people that are
in limbo there are people that are in
hell there are people that are in
purgatory and there are people that are
in heaven and there are people that are
at different levels of heaven
so the story starts with dante falling
into despair he falls into despair he's
at the middle of his life he's been
exiled from his city he basically has
lost all the things that
help he helped him understand who he was
and so he is faced with these three
beasts that are preventing him from
going further he's stuck in a deep dark
forest and he can't go further he has
these three beasts that are facing him
um and so he's stuck
and so in order to get out of that there
appears to him the poet virgil
now for those who don't know virgil is a
roman poet of the first century who
wrote especially the aeneid which is his
most famous poem um
and so dante encounters this poet who's
dead who's been dead for a very long
time and virgil starts to guide him
around these monsters but has to go down
into hell and then come back up to go up
the
the levels of purgatory
but at some point dante asks uh virgil
like you know how is it that you came to
to to greet me like how is it that you
came to get me in my despair
and so what dante describes is that
virgil is in
purgatory he's sorry he's in limbo he's
at the gate of hell and then someone
from above came to see him so beatrice
came to see virgil and beatrice is
dante's
uh muse you could say it's the it's it's
a woman that dante encountered
at some point in his life he never had a
relationship with her he never um
he was never married to her she had her
own life but he saw her as
this this thing that awakened love in
him when he was young so he encountered
this woman it awakened love in him and
she became for him the ideal of of human
love of of arrows the ideal of like
erotic love in in the positive sense
that this thing would draws you forward
which becomes your motor to make you do
things
so beatrice sends
beatrice comes down to
to virgil and says
virgil why don't you go see dante
dante's in trouble
and he and and
you should go and see him so that he can
move forward and she says i was
contacted by saint lucia who is dante's
patron saint
and then there's a hint in which that
saint lucia was contacted by someone
else by another
lady and so it it's not said in the text
but it's the virgin mary basically and
so so you have this interesting setup
where the virgin mary
comes down from god
come from christ comes down from christ
encounters saint lucia and says lucia
dante is in trouble
maybe we could do something about it
your patron saint and now this patron
saint goes down
encounters uh
beatrice who's the woman that awakened
love in dante she says why don't we go
help dante she goes down to limbo and
now she encounters
the pagan poet the greatest poet that
has ever lived you could say uh before
dante in his estimation and now this
poet goes out to find dante now we can
obviously understand this in a narrative
way it's a nice little trope it's a nice
little narrative but it's telling us
about the manner in which
loves
work
the man in which loves stack up on each
other
and so now you saw it from top down
right you saw basically god
calling
god telling or christ telling the virgin
mary telling saint lucia telling
beatrice et cetera et cetera all the way
down but now you can also see it going
up right because that's what's going to
happen with dante so as dante moves up
moves down first into hell then goes up
at some point virgil will leave him and
will be replaced by beatrice as a guide
and as it doesn't it doesn't map on
exactly but it maps on well enough as he
goes up then he then beatrice at some
point is replaced by bernard of
clairvaux who was a great theologian in
the middle ages and then bernardo flavor
leads him up and at some point bernard
leaves and the virgin mary herself takes
dante up into the presence of christ so
that he then enters into the presence of
god
so
this is you can understand that this is
really telling us about how love works
about how loves can build on each other
and so dante's love
for poetry
right dante's love for poetry but not
also you could you could say in terms of
virgil what he rep what he represents is
also all of the secular world
right so there's an there's a
because he's a pagan he represents let's
say secular reality
so all of secular reality all of these
things whether it's poetry whether it's
science whether it's just things that
exist in the secular world
they are the first thing that draws
dante
into the possibility of loving and so
his attraction to these things his
attraction to literature his attraction
to poetry let's say awaken something in
him now if he stayed there
he would
become he would become that stuffy
professor that lives in books and that
doesn't have any connection with reality
and maybe you've met people like that
that live in a world of literature but
have no relationships have no their
lives are a complete mess like their
their relationships are a complete mess
they're they're basically uh like
sociopaths but they know they know
literature like they look they they're
really experts in poetry and all this
stuff so that's a possibility but no
dante that possibility of of of
understanding patterns in
in the world patterns in literature
makes it possible for him to fall in
love
and now he falls in love with this woman
but this woman is is actually uh
unattainable to him
and so here again this could be it's
both a positive and a negative it's
positive because it brings him higher
now it's an actual human relationship
it's not just fictional or like people
on paper it's a real flesh and blood
person standing in front of him you know
who his who now his erotic love can be
directed towards
but then again that's the same now
it's a very it's something which is
positive but could be negative if he
just stayed there
because
someone and again you know this like
someone who's in a relationship and that
relationship fills all their needs and
then they find out that the person is
cheating on them or then without then it
things spiral out of control and they
end up getting a divorce and their lives
are ruined forever
because all their love was put there
something which is good
but which is not all good
right and so
this is now so then dante dante's love
for
beatrice leads him up towards a now a
more spiritual love
right a more spiritual but particular
love which would be something like his
patron saint if you imagine like an
angel you can imagine it like the
capacity to
love something like
it could be something higher in general
like it could be something like a
an ideal you know uh moving towards an
ideal working towards an ideal working
towards something which is higher even
than
our just our human relationships and
becomes a manner in which our human
relationships can be bound together
for some people it could be something
like a cause
you know for some people it could be
something like
like a team you know like a sports team
this is it's lower than a patron saint
but it can help you understand how these
la these loves can kind of scale up into
other loves
and of course now this love leads them
now cosmically to the highest
form of of love which is ultimately this
moving into the virgin and then
ultimately into god himself as
the
absolute good you could say
for modern people it's hard to
understand this like it's hard to
understand this because we tend to
understand god as an arbitrary being
which exists
in heaven or whatever
um you know that's just his arbitrary
being but there's a sense in which the
medieval person or the medievals
understood god as
the source of all good the infinite
source of all good
and therefore all our
love
should move slowly towards the good now
those goods are like i said they are
they are
smaller things they move into virtues
they move into ideals but then
ultimately they also have to move up
towards let's say the source of love
itself
or the possibility of love itself maybe
is the best way to understand that
and
trinitarian theology is
basically a description of love
trinitarian theology is about how
something obviously it's not a thing
right how the source of all things
is both one
and many
at the same time
if you want to understand love that's
basically a definition of love
love is the capacity to be both one and
many at the same time
so
if you love someone
properly
you will want that person to exist
outside of you
because if you suck them into you
right if you basically annihilate them
into your desire
then they will they'll cease to exist
you'll turn them into shadows
you'll turn them into
dreams but true love is the capacity to
both be fully one
with that which is loved while letting
that thing completely exist
outside of you
that is true love
and in the trinity that is what you find
you find basically
a kind of self-emptying love
in which the different persons of the
trinity completely give themselves to
the other while not fusing together and
becoming just a monad you could call it
um
so this description of god ultimately
this is what it's when we say god is
love it's not an arbitrary thing right
it's a it's an actual description of
how god or how the source of all things
animates
our experience animates everything that
we participate in um
and so
this is when this is why
dante i mentioned it i mentioned this
earlier in one of the speeches i read he
says all men though in a vague way
apprehend a good their souls must rest
in and desire it each therefore strives
to reach
its his chosen end
but there's a manner in which that
desire for the good
leads up
into the good itself
leads up into the the highest good and
there's a manner in which that the lower
goods
can be transmuted or transformed into
something which leads you
higher um and this is something which is
obviously there in in christianity but
it's not they're only in christianity
you find it in for example in uh in
plato so in the symposium you really do
find an image of something like that
where the symposium is a drinking party
and of course in the greek culture there
was uh
there was this erotic relationship
between between men of different ages
and so the older men and the younger men
would have these erotic relationships
and it would be
seen in greek culture it was kind of it
was kind of iffy or it was okay but they
weren't sure about it and there's a way
in which socrates in the in the
symposium
he comes into contact with alcibiades
and alcibiades is a very
he's a very passionate person he's an
extremely passionate person he's
extremely driven he has a lot of
ambition
and he really wants to
he he he's like he takes up a lot of
room like he's he's a glorious young man
you know and everybody looks at him
everybody wants him everybody is
attracted to him uh and so ultimately
al-shabaai's according to greek uh
tradition is the one who will betray
greece who will betray athens um but we
don't know that yet
and so alcibiades tries to seduce
socrates and socrates
is constantly if you read the text it's
wonderful socrates is there with
alcibiades as al-sabadi is trying to
seduce him and socrates is constantly
receiving that
receiving alcibiades desire and turning
it towards higher goods
and he's constantly trying to like say
to to bring him to contemplate the forms
to contemplate higher goods uh and of
course al-sabadi's gets very frustrated
in the story he's like he gets very
annoyed he ends up let's say um
admiring uh socrates but you there's a
sense in which in the bigger story of
the symposium and the greek culture
there's a sense in which the fact that
alcibiades was not able to temper his
passions
was not able to temper his loads now not
only for socrates but in general like
you can understand that um someone who
is extremely uh that has a lot of uh
desire to succeed that is extremely
motivated to make it in the world is
someone that is driven right and is
willing to do anything to reach their
goal and so
in the case of alcibiades that love that
strong passion that he had would lead
him ultimately to betray athens and so
if he had learned to moderate his love
and moderate his passions he might have
been able to let's say turn them towards
higher goods and uh and he wouldn't have
uh
he wouldn't have gone the dark route
that that that he has that he has in the
in the story of greece um
and so when you look at in the story of
dante
you can understand that in a christian
manner the best way to understand it is
something like
compassion and so you can understand
that the way that the love that moves up
is something like admiration or
something like veneration
something like seeing
seeing something as a model that
attracts you towards it
and then the love which comes down from
the higher goods is something like
self-sacrificial or compassionate and so
it's by it's through compassion that the
virgin calls down on these lower loves
to then draw
dante in
and dante isn't ready for the higher
things so there's a way in which he must
he must let's say truly explore
the loves that are there present present
to him that is his desire to become a
great poet his desire to to learn about
poetry is something which is good
and he needs to fully
he needs to fully accomplish you could
say
but
also always
knowing that it
eventually has to move up towards
higher and uh and higher goods um
and so i would say that that was
basically like let's say the
the basic thought that i wanted to bring
you guys and i was hoping that there
would be questions because i know that
this is maybe something that you hadn't
thought about uh and is not maybe
obvious at the first glance or maybe it
is i don't know so i would love to hear
questions from you so that we can
continue the discussion
i know it's not like say your
job to like help fix other people's
lives that's not the
uh
like angle that i'm asking this question
from but when you see somebody who's
maybe like loving excessively and you
can see that it's like to a point of
harm
as a friend or whatever like
how would you like suggest like what
advice would you suggest giving to like
navigate that and help them maybe see
um
maybe like a third view perspective of
like why it might be detrimental yeah
it's very difficult because someone that
is drunk
on on love is very difficult to
reason into
reason into anything it's very hard
that's why like i i won't lie to you
that's why in dante that's why people
are in hell
there's a sense in which the people that
are in hell are completely drunk
on their love of the thing that's making
them that's bringing them there they're
so drunk on it that there's
no almost no way to get them out of it
it's like they're they're completely
blind and turning in their circle of
desire um
and so it's very difficult to do that
but i think that it's possible and i
think that
i think that um
let's say modeling proper love or
modeling proper compassion is probably
the best way to do this which is that if
you have a friend that is
that is
obsessed with something or someone to a
level that it's self-destructive then i
think
the best thing to do
is to
let's say kindly tell them
take the wrath
and let that person know that you're
still gonna be there like you're not
going anywhere right that is like okay
i'm gonna tell you that this i think is
is is dangerous to you and then that
person will say
whatever if you i hate you i don't want
to talk to you again and you and you're
like okay i get it but i'm here like if
you need me i'm here and i'm not going
anywhere like i'll still i'm still your
friend i'm i i feel important it's
important for me to tell you this and
i'll be here you know and then when that
person crashes which obviously was gonna
happen
then to be there for that person when
they do
um
but it's tough because love is that
right love is the
is our driving is our driving force so
hopefully that helps a little yeah
uh okay maybe i missed this when you
spoke about it but how do our loves for
let's say our work uh
you know jogging um friendships how do
they bring us to a higher good
well it depends it depends on on the
love but let's say
jogging is a good
but the good of jogging is to make you
healthy right
that's that's the good you're aiming
towards but you know some people that
stop aiming towards that
and then just become weirdly obsessed
with physical activity and the physical
activity now becomes like the thing they
do and now they're not doing physical
activity in order to be healthy
they're just doing physical activity as
if it had it was the goal in itself and
it's the same with work like you know
people that
like
love what they do love their work love
what they're doing and you know people
that are slaves of their work
and become completely enslaved by their
work and see it as their only
identity
as the thing which gives them value
and so they'll work insane amount of
hours because they think that it's the
only thing that makes them exist
basically
and so then it becomes completely
apparent but if you if you're if your
work it stimulates your mind it
stimulates your it stimulates your um
uh you know your capacity to learn new
things it brings you into contact with
other people that you that you create
bonds with that you create friendships
with then the love of work becomes
something which is balanced with other
loves and kind of lead you into
higher loves which would be friendships
that you develop at work uh you know
whatever it can lead you to it can also
it also it provides money for you to be
able to live out other goods you know
which are to have a relationship to have
children to
to to to maybe focus on certain causes
that you want to be involved in certain
higher things which are
let's say more to the service of
humanity like help the poor or whatever
it is that you do all these things can
can kind of fit together and it's it's
usually when we become
when we try to put all our identity into
one love that's usually when it becomes
uh
becomes uh out of whack
so my question is okay so like i agree
with you but how can we ourselves so uh
jane was asking okay how can we help
someone else realize that that obsession
they have for something
he's not healthy but if we don't have
anyone around us how can we notice that
that
like okay so it's like yeah you don't
need to love since the certain extent
and i guess my answer and the answer
would be that it doesn't prevent you
from going to higher things but how can
you detect that maybe they are putting
in something or someone it's too
excessive it's not proportional yeah if
you're a uh if you're a religious person
then that is makes it easier
like if you're a religious person then
it's kind of set out for you which is
that
there are there are
there's a hierarchy of goods and so
you have an objective scale that you can
look at and realize that you know if
if i'm neglecting these higher goods
like if i'm neglecting my
if i'm neglecting worship that is
attending to the highest good if i'm
neglecting becoming more virtuous
then that is also
a good which is competing etc etc like
if it's if it's
if this good is
destroying my relationships
then those are all signs that the the
the different goods are not in their
proper order and so
praying itself
or i'll be generous to you because i'll
say if you meditate for example is
something that can help you because one
of the problem with these loves is that
they they drive us into a circle of
passion right it's like they drive us
from desire anticipation
to fulfillment to depression to desire
to anticipation to fulfill and so it's
like this wheel that keeps going and so
once you're in that wheel it's very
difficult because you're you're like a
little gerbil running and you're like
you're just trying to make it go but
that's why something like stopping
you're stopping your activity stopping
what you're doing and then praying or at
least being meditating and just being in
silence for 10 15 minutes a day for
example is something which will
definitely help you because what it'll
do is it'll pull you out of the
pull you out of the wheel
just for a little moment it doesn't even
have to be that long but just being
pulled out of that wheel of like all the
thoughts that are running in your mind
for a little while will help you to see
more with more clarity the things that
are driving you and you're going to
start to see them because what's going
to happen
is
when you're going to start to want to
pray
all of a sudden you won't be able to
because these things are going to start
seeping back into you
so you're if you can't if you if you try
to stop thinking about something and you
can't that's a bad sign
that's a bad sign
right if you if you're just saying okay
i'm not going to think about this now
i'm just going to stop in silence and
not think about anything let's say and
then those thoughts just come crashing
back in then i would say
it's a it's a sign that you're in
trouble like they're not in big trouble
it's it's most people are slaves to some
of these things but it's a it's
something to be attentive to to know
that okay i need to
to maybe refocus some of the things that
i'm focusing on and something everybody
has that i go through it all the time
because i love what i do i love my work
and then i get all these people asking
me to to come speak here and to do this
and do that and so i'm all of a sudden
i'm like i'm running and i'm super
excited and i've got you know like my
adrenaline level is super high and i've
got all these endorphins coming in i'm
like
and then i realized okay i'm drunk
basically i'm just drunk on this thing
and it's really bad for me because you
know it's like oh i'd rather do that
than call my friend like i'd rather be
in this world than than let's say do the
things that i know that i need to do um
so that's a way to to to be attentive to
it but in in terms of like so i'm i'm an
orthodox christian and there are a lot
of things there to help you do that like
confession is a great way to deal with
that because when you have to go to
confession
uh with a priest
it's like all of a sudden you have to
think about it like you have to think
about those thoughts that you've got
you've got to think about those actions
that you pose and you've got to ask
yourself like okay what are the things
that are motivating what are the things
that are driving me and so it's a good
way to to reflect you can go see a
psychologist it's not as good but it can
help
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please uh
go ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support